e aí que ela esteja na altura vocês hoje
votar mais uma historinha pra vocês
quando era pequeno a minha irmã tem que
fazer uma operação que eu tenho que
viajar e meus irmãos foram juntos minha
mãe eu para mim como não tínhamos
dinheiro nem identificar quem pode ficar
ou o inverso cedo esse tempo me mandar
para o tratamento tem certeza que lá eu
fiquei na minha volta e eu não vou viver
na roça é a minha bota e ficar falando
comigo como eu vou poder chegar na roça
então fazer connie um dia ninguém pelo
brincar não tinha energia elétrica
utilizando degradante de esquadro tinha
que tá em que nada ou seja uma parte da
minha infância eu passei muito isolado
não tinha menino tinha nada não tinha
brinquedo é mesmo a não saber de nada
ter uma noção eu achava que as crianças
na cio de ovo gigante tipo de um lugar
na terra onde estava lotado de ouro ea
galera tipo sair de novo ea procurar
alguém passei para a semana eu jurava
que as crianças nascessem aí índia com a
mulher grávida na casa da minha mãe eu
comecei a noite teve tem noção de como
virá essa menina tem como não saber que
a gente ouve ninguém pois achava que nem
muito feliz aí eu vou falar assim mas
quando é que vai ganhar esse menino aí
eu só que eu ou na hora entende que uma
pessoa fique com a barriga desse tamanho
e isso é um sinal que alguém vai dar uma
criança de presente pra ela não quer
dizer que toda pessoa que tem a barriga
desse tamanho alguém vai lá e tal filho
presente na época e desde agora entende
que meu pai tem quatro filhos ea mulher
respondeu sim eu tô com tanto medo de
parentes a criança
só dói não é com alegria se rende e
levado à segurança assim me dando
malamadre pega fim assim a fazer linha
logo mal tá essa meta está engolindo as
crianças saiu aí que minha loja e
explicar como é que eu treinasse e eu
como um menino que aprende rápido a
folha como inteligente ela me ensinou e
um brinde que a cegonha é a melhor
pessoa para entregar a criança vamos lá
onde andava na escola ouvi um monte de
ministérios lutando pega o celular para
ver um vídeo e um monte de me sentar se
e peça para dançar lá chega para o mpf a
questão de gente aqui é que o rio tietê
um vídeo pornô o time relaxou o veículo
eu fiquei naquela porque tudo de mim não
sei que fui a diretoria na diretora que
cheguei a diretora do colégio perguntei
diretora o que é bom no hotel e ninguém
saber se a menina comentou pega o
shitake com toda a caminhada da imitou
ela inventou a resposta pra mim por eu
não saber o que era por um home sou eu o
estou indo se tornou é uma pessoa muito
boa uma pessoa que uma pensão de ajuda
às pessoas uma pessoa que não tá mal a
ninguém sabe o meu filho vestindo sabia
com longe sei lá
agora me liguei os caras acabam se
juntando a assistir uma boa ação eu fui
pra casa
cheguei em casa minha mãe que acaba de
chegar do trabalho é o filme lehmann que
foi o filho
eu sou humor nou
[Música]
ela quando descobriu que era um novo meu
deus deu a beleza depois eu aprendi o
garoto pulou a pele como é que a criança
nascer a semente entanto longe eu fui
procurar assistir um filme tropa de
elite com apoio da nike tinha ninguém
desse filme é negada falando em que
existiam que andaram 75 a chegada do
colega meio e ele tinha só por dever
dele era todos organizados atacar pirata
todos deverei capa de cd e ainda achamos
que tinha sintoma de elite não foi de
papel e por dentro na guarda o dvd ela é
a cheia do rio taquari e vez na casa
abrir o aparelho dvd e eu defender o teu
dever e já apareceu aquela mensagem este
filme é proibido para menores de 18 anos
lei não sei te dizer que ela a lei
antifumo disse que uma curva saiu sangue
30 até integrar a área pois é ela que
este filme contém cenas de sexo música
me sinto em meus irmãos que vai voltar
ao trabalho até então existia qualquer
captação patury das atacante abrir o
menu do mundo teve gente pelada que
mutti falei na am afirmou que matava se
um da abbey tado para a taça na mão a
síndrome da mulher do outro lado da
piscina é melhor começar a dançar
sensualmente que o cara do outro lado da
piscina
aí do nada de outro cara normal
aí o cara olhou pra mulher leopoldo cara
ai foi no mundo o cara chegou no outro
cara é começou a passar mal do cara aí
ele começou a oscar começar a pega
primeiro filme bobo assistir a minha
vida por nome e até hoje aquela cena na
minha cabeça ou amigo fala na [ __ ] que
me emprestou esse dever para ele vir
jogar o nome dele aqui na internet agora
é saber se essa realidade na casa dele
foi pai
a vida é assim um dia você é inocente
não sabe nada no outro você assiste
pornô gay e graças a deus graças a deus
não teve reflexo na minha vida a minha
edição foi o cara pra mim foi uma
surpresa do cão eu quero você comente
aqui embaixo qual foi a maior surpresa e
já aconteceu com você
a história da minha vida é curta
história íntima minha com que só eu
profundo insisto não dentro da empresa
do meu coração sabe não dá lhe neste
vídeo você né a casa gostei desse vídeo
pornô gay e seu inimigo assistir e não
também planeta no entanto a primeira vez
de táxi a primeira vez que está
assistindo o vídeo news clique
inscrevesse que toda vez que tiver
ouvindo você vai saber ea esse dia eu
vou gravar um vídeo respondendo às
perguntas do twitter e também sair aqui
no twitter que é o primeiro a descrição
do vídeo falou de ligar a equipe já à
tarde os visitam dormir aqui falou que
agora vá assistir um com 12 em barra e o
nó é ter um taepodong 1 8